you
I'm Jen from head to toe my makeup
channel is frm hme 20
hi I'm Ted a Philip less from wall for
productions and we're at e3 right now
dude is one this freestyle and ER I won
that it's exclusive to e3 no one can
have this but me hot dog this year's e3
is pretty interesting because all the
major consoles are coming out you gotta
pitch in for you got a xbox one I can do
Mario looks really fun I just like fun
as opposed to just games I hate most
games like coming out these days like I
really don't enjoy so I'm gonna play all
the nintendo stuff I'm gonna play don't
become country-pop very berry blitz or
whatever it's called the slurpee a
strawberry surf rider Charmander
fighters strawberry surf rider no
picture squeeze citrus cool guy ice what
does it cold ice climbers no no no no no
it's a loja pineapple freeze easy peak
law pineapple here we go I just finished
playing Pikmin behind me right now
I really like intend oh I'm hoping to
find a dance central area and I really
want to play the new plants vs zombies
I'm looking forward to a new minesweeper
hope that it's going to be pretty
awesome here there's going to be new
graphics and you characters stop park
the stick of truth is all that we're
playing awesome castlevania allergic
channel 20 there's only that oh yeah
that's great I'm actually interested see
if santa monica studios here they made a
journey so I want to see it I'm see what
they're up to Sony's going after
hardcore gamers but there's not a lot of
hardcore gamers out there compared to
your casual / regular you know regular
gamers Microsoft's going after just
people who want like entertainment boxes
like Tebow's and you know that sort of
thing so they're not really going after
a gamer crime or Nintendo's always been
the same way they'll always be like hey
we're do we do toys that's what we're
going after so it's frankly the first
time Matt the other guy made me dig in
high schools talking a lot about this
the first time you see a lot of these
companies take really different stances
you know it's like ps3 and xbox 360 were
baseless and console and everybody was
developing for both of those so for the
first time I think you're seeing a
divergence so we needed to see which way
it goes in which one's better I think
once it's like better than the other and
0 PS fours been going after the gamer
crowd but I don't like iPhones aren't
for the gamer crowd either and they sell
pretty well so maybe Microsoft has a
thing going there too will be
interesting how people react to it this
is the best III yet shoutout to
Microsoft you definitely won oh yes box
one I think it's pretty much unanimous
everyone wait III and I love this system
that keeps me company because it watches
me whole day if I don't like being alone
side of my xbox with me i also like i
say a lot of money somebody gets the
xbox one as well and not too crappy
cheap he wants to feel the hard work I'm
not gonna do that no we don't do chintz
here now
we you hey just step aside no it's
killing it depend on killing it by far
best game at e3 is up go ahead i'm going
to go ahead i'm going to give a
exclusive yeah new media rockstars
exclusive yeah kingdom hearts 3 is going
to be the best game of the show it's not
playable but it's going to be the best
and i'm going to drop a world exclusive
there is a level finally sora meets the
Apple Dumpling gang oh they read there's
a cg don knotts i've already seen the
art tetsuo Nomura he got the goal you'd
rue de la cible didn't steal it off Don
Knotts has a lot of buckets
you